tell me about that purse and what is in  it it is very heavy  I travel lightly there is a sandwich in  my purse because I I was smart this time  the other awards I I was hungry I'm  starving and sometimes either they don't  have food or I don't care for the food  they're so so smart Thank You Preston  Syriana he is so good at it isn't he  [Music]  how excited are you for all the folks in  your movie especially Brad and we  looking they deserve all the success  that is coming to them and that has come  to them and they're just truly wonderful  people with such amazing hearts you keep  in touch with them like you call them up  and say hey Brad you're going to the  BAFTAs or Independent Spirit Award I  keep it professional  I'm turning 11 April 15th everybody  tonight just the shoulder over the  shoulder just sometimes I might do it  fake laugh  [Music]